how can you tastefully send a dick thick
hey just get lazy what if I'm being
honest hi my name is Morgan I work in
the television industry I love to go on
runs in my free time and I also love to
travel but I'm hoping to get out of
today is just to meet a nice guy that
hopefully I could go on a date with well
think
[Music]
[Music]
I'm looking for a guy that nice funny
has good family values and it's all
because I'm super tall little nervous
what the games begin
I'm missing new greeting at first oh she
just texted to all of us
hi guys my name is Morgan Morgan now
like nervous I say hey hi
do we emoji back she gave us our G still
waiting didn't capitalize her own name
huh
hello I'm Leo this is my favorite emoji
you did the nerdy emoji oh my god sue
yeah hey Morgan I'm ashamed I know moji
playing coy I like that no emoji judging
you keep it simple hello there Morgan my
name is Ben chicken the rooster is the
best emoji live its its icon it reloaded
dumb-looking how many dating apps you
currently have on your phone oh boy oh
my good man why it's taking me so long
and they're like counting like never
what I admit that I'm even on those
things that's bad if I don't zero dating
apps zero dating apps not your average
millennial respect dot dot dot two dot
dot dot to like does that mean like I'm
only thinking of two right now like off
of the top of my head or like I had
multiple and then I deleted them I have
two but I would delete them are you
gonna shoot a line now for you oh wow
but I would delete them for you baby and
one just wrote in woo the kitchen is hot
I have no idea like we weren't okay
we're gonna ask them what their go-to
pick-up line is pickup line straight
yeah how do you slide into the end
sooner to is you up okay like am i up
like am i awake
that is a ballsy move honestly hello I
am very wealthy and handsome
that works I mean wealthy is a relative
term one says hey what's up here's this
hey what's up with just the emotion I
think you could do better the paper eyes
just aren't my thing it's better than
mine okay so far I'm leaning towards
three and not because he's wealthy and
handsome just because well part of the
reason I'm very traditional I like when
the guy pays on the first date would you
let the woman pay on the first date yeah
what I let her what's it's not my yeah
of course absolutely go for it girl okay
by all means pay for dinner I really not
feeling one I think we're doing pretty
well here at all we'll need a second
round of drinks because the first one is
on me okay so we're like splitting the
check if I like this girl if I like this
girl and it was going well I would not
if she was hard to stand we're splitting
it or not I think that's fair that's
fair
where's the taco emoji so we're having a
taco party what do you put in the taco I
mean like let's get real it's kind of
sexual but that's a way to say like
who's vegan who's vegetarian I knew
she's gonna bring up tacos I don't know
I knew this sooner three said tacos are
tight I freaking love them Suter to say
great question I love tacos tacos and
then suitor one said I put a taco in my
taco say it's a wait you've got tacos
where they're just saying I love tacos
I've havin too much fun with myself so
apparently these they all like tacos
which cereal describes you and why
frosted flakes because I'm great I'm
great I'm great
what do you put and then fruity pebbles
cuz love wins cuz love wins and then
three said honey bunches of oats because
I'm sweet like honey and I got a bunch
of love or something this is a bad
answer
and now let's let's get serious again
I'm gonna ask for what are these guys
looking for what are you looking for
girl shoot it's a big question we're
gonna silence in the room like huh so
many things number three a sense of
humor intelligence easy to talk to you
kind and maybe rides a motorcycle did
you cover no I should do it a psycho
thing in there good feet I'm looking for
a sense of humor too motorcycle I hate
motorcycles three definitely knows what
he wants love a girl who's in dabble in
sports I love a girl who's athletic
that's definitely me I do love to run
and I love a good outdoor activity yeah
man this is hard yeah number one has
been the slowest you guys are covering
all the bases right now how am I
supposed to like follow up okay so he
just wrote in Mike's dogs likes to eat
she's got to be weird she's got to be
weird like what do you mean weird type
of girl who goes to museum but also
shotguns a beer shotguns a beer she
could shotgun a beer that's what if she
shotgun the beer at a museum oh I want
to find out how tall these guys are but
I'm trying to think of a creative way to
ask that without just being straight up
what sports do you play well boys what
sports do you play golf play I play a
lot of golf I'm guessing that he's
five-nine five-ten all right now I'm not
gonna put in I got a solid answer I said
I eat out often and that requires walk
into the restaurant if that counts if
that counts no well yeah that's exercise
three Road I'm sorry I used to play
basketball but the only sport I do now
is surf I'm into that now three seems
like he's a jokester kind of quick and
sarcastic which I like to seems like
he's traditional a little bit more
old-fashioned probably a little of a
quieter guy number one just seems boring
so these are my last questions I'm gonna
get a little bit more intense over here
have you ever sent a dick sick I hate
when I like dick here isn't a sick pic
Wow Wow
so we just turned it up a notch here
imagine if a guy like has an album
gross I just kids like the relevant what
about like we should call it a penis
portrait okay
suitor one no but I'm open-minded I
could be swayed sitter - I don't think
we're there in our relationship to
discuss that Morgan that is a very
private question it's like I don't think
we're there yet sooner - shy soon or
three probably is like an album I have
but but in the privacy in the privacy of
a relationship and only wine that they
asked me and tastefully done how can you
tastefully send a dick thick they just
get lazy what if I'm being honest
refusing emojis describe our first date
I've always wanted to tell a story with
emojis I'm just gonna do the 100 emoji
so Studio three or a hundred a hundred
100 emoji and then he wrote the monkey
with the cost out and they wrote music
chicken TM and love that's a thinker
it's for me this it looks like our dates
going really well then we're gonna get
really close and do something and then
we're gonna go to a concert eat chicken
and fall in love okay you know you got
the holding hands emoji roses you know
you gotta bust out flowers I'm a classy
type of guy champagne pop some bottles a
turkey stick some dinner you know turkey
leg soup dancing dancing that's what my
lightning happens lightning cuz that's
where I'm at best he's confident that
this guy was like pretty creative I'm
kind of surprised that one see there -
wrote money kiss dancing martinis taco
ice cream singing a little martini a
taco maybe go out for ice cream after
Mike drop kind of leaning towards Souter
- because I like to dance and I like to
drink martinis so for my last question
now now that you all know each other why
should I pick you over the last two guys
that's enough breaker
listen up Morgan c-13 I saw you want
these two boys are jump they're all
turning on each other
oh and PU they also smell see their
number two I'm tallest wait how tall you
six - I'm 63 baby
doesn't work sitter three I also love my
mom and this you've been talking [ __ ]
about their like there's gotta be that
deal-breaker sorry guys I'm going with
they're actually Aldo see that's a good
route you can't lose they're actually
dope I like them all you really can't
lose either way I don't like that I like
a guy that like stands up for what he
wants compassion takes bigger so I guess
that's it now we find out one doesn't
seem like he knows what he wants
feel like he's gonna go with Leo you
know I feel like she's gonna go so it's
between two or three three is definitely
a confident guy that knows what he wants
but I feel like three it's a little bit
shorter I feel like two is taller which
is kind of drawing me more towards - I
choose dot dot dot
[Music]
so this is what it's like to be on The
Bachelor of Man just week after week the
rose I don't know if I could do it oh I
love stick I'm gonna have to go with
three three gosh you have better taste
you have phase three you have bad days
hi nice to meet you yeah I should have
put more thought into it and wasn't so
nonchalant with my answers where
actually I guess that works for been so
high there's no real way to prepare it
just wasn't my day maybe I got a date
I got tacos coming I'm very glad you
chose me I was not expecting that
and I wish I had a dress better yeah you
are at the lesson you should learn from
me is to never take yourself too
seriously that was a lie it's okay you
know you're much better
[Music]
[Music]